Today, I want to talk about thinking
in the language we are learning.
It comes up all the time.
How do I get to where I can think
in the language I'm learning?
To me, this is related to this other
question of how can I speak like a native?
And here, I think we need to understand,
at least my view of the whole process
of language learning is we start out
at basically zero, knowing nothing
or very little, we may know related
languages, but we're at the very
beginning and there's this continuous.
Sort of voyage, which eventually takes
us to a higher level, but that higher
level is very rarely, if ever, perfection.
I just don't think perfection
is a term we can think of when
we think of language learning.
If we come to this question of thinking
in the language So even languages that
I speak very well in, say, my own case,
in Japanese, in French, there are always
times when I will translate from English.
I may not do that for the longest time.
I might feel very comfortable in the
language, but there will inevitably
come some point where I am actually
using a structure or a word that I've
reached into my brain for in English.
And I translate it into the language.
It's a continuum.
So, as we're getting better and better
in the language, there are moments when
we hear something, it's instant meaning.
We read something, it's instant meaning.
We go to say something
and it just comes out.
And so there, we are, in a way,
thinking in the language we're
learning, but we're doing it for, you
know, a small part of the time that
we are spending with the language.
As we continue, as we become more
comfortable, we get better at it.
As with so much in language learning,
the deliberate effort to learn
something is often counterproductive.
The deliberate effort to avoid
thinking in the language just makes
you uptight and makes it, you know,
less likely that you will achieve that.
You have to relax and let it happen.
It will gradually happen.
More and more, you will start thinking
in the language, if you continue with
all of your language learning activities.
And I think this concept of Thinking
in the language is related to
sort of speaking like a native.
I have said before, I don't think
we can achieve a hundred percent,
you know, sounding like a native.
There will always be something
that betrays you as not a
speaker of that language, but
you can become very, very good.
And in this whole issue of this sort
of continuum, where we start in the
language and you get better and better.
It brings up these two terms that
I see very often from linguists.
One is interlanguage and
the other is fossilization.
And apparently those two terms
were developed by a professor
of linguistics, Larry Selnicker.
So interlanguage explains the ability.
The ability of people to speak better in
the language they're learning because of
the influence of their native language.
And so structures and even vocabulary
items, not to mention pronunciation
from their native language will
influence how they speak in
the language they're learning.
To me, that's obvious.
I'm not sure why we need
a term like interlanguage.
Native speakers of certain languages
will tend to make the same kinds of
mistakes that reflect patterns and
structures in their own language.
They don't all do that.
Some do, some don't.
But to some extent, these
patterns are Reflective of the
native language of the speaker.
That's normal.
We use what we know and what we're
comfortable using, and we apply that
to the things that we're learning.
It's even suggested that learners
might speak or produce the language
better in a classroom drill setting.
But then in a casual conversation,
they revert back to interlanguage.
But that to me is normal because
you can have a structured
environment in a classroom.
You can have the impression
that something's been
taught, but once you revert.
Say, a couple of days later, when you're
in a normal situation, and possibly a
stressful situation, then that deliberate
learning may not help you that much,
although probably does contribute to
gradually getting better in the language.
Again, fossilization is presented as some
kind of a final stage in interlanguage
because some learners simply don't
progress beyond a certain point.
So they're stuck at this interlanguage
or this less than optimal level in the
language and they don't get better.
But I think we continue to
think in our own language to
some extent, varying degrees.
We continue to use structures
that reflect our native language.
That's always the case.
But I think if we put enough effort
into listening and reading, and if we
are relaxed about it, and don't say,
I want to speak better, but we aren't
prepared to put in the hours of listening
and hours of listening and Thousands
and hundreds of thousands of words of
reading to allow our brains to get a
better sense of the language, then we're
not going to get beyond that point.
However, it's important to remember
that many speakers of a second
language are, in effect, fossilized.
They have come to a level, it might be
a very high level, where they are happy.
And I'm this way in a number
of languages that I speak.
Good enough.
I can communicate.
I understand.
People understand me.
I'm good.
I'm happy.
It's even suggested in one of these papers
that, to some extent, the interlanguage
may be an expression of identity.
I think that's unlikely.
However, I've mentioned this before, even
my father, who spoke English very, very
well, had larger vocabulary than I did.
I think at some level it bothered him
that English spelling was so inconsistent
and therefore he would pronounce English
words as if they were written in Czech.
So as I've said, Bank of Nova Scotia
was Scotia, Nova Scotia, because
to him somehow TIA should be.
And so there's a sort of a
psychological element of resisting
the new language, which is also, I
think, not an unimportant factor.
But my father thought in the
language, I'm a hundred percent
sure he thought in English, but
he didn't speak like a native.
So it's possible to get to a level
where we think in the language
where it's instant meaning.
We express ourselves, not necessarily like
a native, but without thinking about it.
So we are thinking that we're in
the language, but our utterances are
not a hundred percent native like.
All of these things, to my mind, are part
of language learning, of communicating,
of the fact that we cannot expect
perfection in language learning, and
we shouldn't beat ourselves up if we
don't yet feel that we think in the
language as well as we would like, or
we aren't as fluent as we would like.
All of these things are perfectly normal.
And so I would leave you with a couple of
videos I did on the whole issue of errors.
The importance of errors, if we recognize
our own errors, that helps us learn.
But at the same time, learning
to live with our less than
perfect use of the language.
Bye for now.